this video is sponsored by Shopify more
on them after the
[Music]
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
hello it's your boy Aaron here and I'm
here with the one the only it's me I'm
not going to do the Adam Sandler voice
today it's John it's John and we're here
to watch the one big daddy the grand
large father Adam Sandler himself and
from what I've heard Dylan and Cole
sprous are in this movie as a child
playing one child not two children
stacked in a trench coat stacked in a
trench coat yeah to be one large child
man guys what do you know about Big
Daddy are you a big daddy are you a
little daddy do you like kids I don't
know that's don't answer that I mean do
you have kids you have kids do you have
kids you know let them know that you're
watching the real rejects cuz that's you
you watch us we watch you no we don't
anyway leave a comment leave a like
subscribe ring that gosh dang Bell in
honor of Tara shout out to terara Erics
she's healing up as I'm recording this
video ring the bell for that girl and
thank you thank you thank you so much to
prepper because they're doing the real
work the hard work by editing down these
highlights and also don't forget to go
over the patreon to watch Greg and John
do so many highlights over there so many
movies so many TV shows where you sync
up with your own copy and enjoy the
fulllength ride with those boys okay
heck to the Gap all right did I cover
all the things you got it was so groovy
covered all the things we're groovy
we're movie We're watching a movie Hell
yeah all right John are you ready to
watch this movie let's do it do it
Yoo
oh okay we got some big Bas Big Daddy
enormous father you know what it
is let's go talk to him sunny it's your
dad you asleep no hey man I I was I was
exercising uh damn this is me
every morning oh yeah okay Dad I act
like I'm six relatable wipe your chin
any luck finding a job where you can
work more than one day a week I've been
looking that's the dream doesn't pay the
rent kid I want a boat all the money I
won from the cab accident is kicking ass
in the stock markets don't P all on
worthless crap got a
settlement you know what you should
spend it on your bar exam you're the
lawyer in the family I ain't taking a
damn bar exam I got too much other
going on in my life like these beats I
would think's going with your girlfriend
what's it Vanessa things are going fine
oh no oh whoa oh my God it's
um she looks familiar who is he oh my
God what is her name Andrew would know
he would why are you going to work it's
Sunday I'm not going to work I'm going
to brunch with some potential clients
people work on Sundays Adam Sandler
brunch is work work that's how a party
planner gets business by meeting people
making contact God what oh it's going to
drive me nuts the comments will tell us
a thousand this a rough patch of my life
right now all right Syracuse is only
three oh medical problems medical
problems a cab runs over your foot two
years ago you spend one night in the
hospital I slipped on pee at the Megalo
Mart one night of pain was worth
$200,000 so there you go whatever damn
what the hell's the matter with you you
sh like looks like Miss minutes
yeah a little bit how she wake up with a
hair looking so good who told you'll be
that fine on a Sunday I mean you don't
wake up like
that GE speak for yourself my friend my
hair is kind of like a foof in the
morning I on the other hand would like
to have a family someday but I need
someone that I can rely on not just a
playmate you need Carlton Lasser all
right I'm going to go to Syracuse to see
my mom I'll be back on Wednesday God
that is a brunch fit she's going in the
broad the jacket you know she's call for
delivery in building but I think it was
crank call want some chocolate
cake I'll take it Rob sneer you're going
down sucker yeah we'll see about that
okay peace out I want a full breakdown
on the what races Rob Schneider plays in
these
movies where you going Manhattan
Manhattan you want to take me with
you I guess all right your
moneyy it's like everlas
I have no idea but I like it who music
supervised
this
uh it's only Sunny only sunny it's
freaking Leslie man oh I know her name
Young Leslie man surprise going away
party for K why didn't she tell me about
it the roommate has a right to know cuz
she knew you'd tell him and ruin the
surprise no I wouldn't yeah you would
John Stewart start oh
no oh no why nobody closed the door no
yeah why didn't they reset we wasted the
good surprise on you all
right dang oh
no this your handiwork I guess see in
three
hours a a nice to do damage control for
his own birthday party yeah don't worry
he'll become Half Baked John Stewart and
soon enough
honey your sister's here hey sweetie I
hate Sunny my client's out 7 million
bucks and all we can sue on his breach a
contract maybe you can try suing under
the Foreign Corrupt Practices
light the office Sunny you're the King
right dude if he would just apply
himself he could be a great lawyer he'
be a great lawyer he'd be a great daddy
exactly those two go hand in hand I'm
still a little weird of that one that
kiss why they're gay that's what gay
guys do yeah that's all they
do they're still like our brothers our
very very gay brothers damn dude join
the 21st century my friend sign these
movies woke
yeah and then I'll go on to make Chuck
and Larry and make this whole thing more
confusing well you're not going to let a
little rain stop you from making oh is
that Jennifer Tilly no I like where your
head's at though okay she had a similar
voice to her I wanted to thank you all
for coming tonight uh or I guess I
should
say Spanish tomorrow I'm leaving for
China to represent the fine firm of
Morton and Mandel yes me the same guy
who once shaved his ass to win a $5 bet
prove
it oh jeez man oh cuz he's gay makes
sense I'm about to do something that I
never thought I'd have the guts to do
you're not proposing are
you no you're the worst you are the the
wingman everybody deserves yeah pal I am
well think about it you
know why would you say that you're awful
bro you oh no
dude
yeah she goes back into the bathroom
ruined it again ruin the surprise no
John Stewart goes to the
bathroom congratulations you andig m
going to be real happy all her Big
M you met their mother while she was
waitressing at Hooters son that was 5
years ago she's a doctor now and my
fiance from now on that's awesome good
for
her Hooter's waitresses are people too
vaness is going to break up with me is
just getting older she wants different
things you know career stable
relationship a family guy knows things
about the news I just want things to go
back to the way they used to be like
when we were at Syracuse and Vanessa
worshiped you yes that was nice nice
nobody was hassling you to get a job
Tommy and Phil were showering
separately everyone's really adjusting
harshly to their gay friends I like when
John Stewart acts it's fun he didn't do
it too often yeah I'm cleaning because
you're useless and then what are you
going to go to your Hooters reunion you
guys can sit around talk about whose ass
hangs out of their shorts the most Le I
can fit my ass into my shorts daddy oh
damn that's how he becomes Big
Daddy
yeah lady gave me $5 to bring him over
here what do you mean later whoa you've
been served that's a different movie
John sorry my bad my
bad a little sprous little CH head
little Zach and Cody there's a kid here
uh what kind of kid uh if this not is
true it's your kid what I think it says
Dear Kevin this is Julian your son I
hope you understand why I didn't tell
you about him until now but he needs
your help what can't be his mother
anymore this is ridiculous look at his
futuristic old cell phone is that Kevin
on the phone no it's my Uncle
Remis Uncle re show him
good is he all
right yeah he just doesn't like you
leave us alone that was your girlfriend
she was acting really hfic
again jeez man I don't know any Jam
where's she from where you from Buddy
Janet from Friends Buffalo a I've never
even been to Buffalo somebody's messing
with me maybe it's a mistake come on is
there really a kid there or is this like
the time you told me my parents were
dead huh if you won't take
responsibility for them they found a
foster family that yes Uncle Remis I
know the catfish are huge that's
terrific weird pool I better come home
no no no no let me take care of it you
sure you can take care of this yeah I'll
be fine don't
worry Hooters Hooters
don't worry everything's going to get
figured out tomorrow can you be a tough
little guy until
then
great do I need to get you a bottle of
formula or something no what do you eat
food but what kind of food there's so
many you got a lot of options kid I hope
it's like the movie Repo Man where food
just comes in big generic cans that say
food eat it yeah how old are you anyways
five five a little
diaper in real life he was 20 wipe your
own ass then yes you do good job that's
cool that makeup was crazy back then
down yes on damn you suck you suck you
suck check this out got a lot of anger
repressed man notice he plays those kind
of characters a
lot Adam Sandler works it out in front
of us the
audience Lees it all at work we are his
thing oh wow there's a stick there
somebody should move
it this Columbo he pretends to be stupid
but he's really smart as a t i wi my own
ass that's great kid me too hey we all
be wiping love that for you wiper uh
what's this guy's name Scuba Steve Scuba
Steve that's where this comes from Scuba
Steve oh shoot I've heard that before
but I didn't know it came from here I
had a doll like that one time but my cat
he biked his head off what kind of cat
would do that you calling me a liar oh
you want a Go kid yeah no music during
the game it's half time relax God damn
jet what are you doing in here cutie not
this year Watching football who do you
want to win the godamn
Jets too bad you don't like girls I
think you could have had
her that's that's called that's that's
my boy slow
down what do you want a soda you allowed
soda no my mother always said that soda
rots your teeth but you're going to lose
them teeth anyway so rot on right rot on
that's fun way to look at it we used to
meet here every Monday night to watch
football who would meet you my friends
Vanessa Vanessa always used to rooe
against the team I wanted to win just to
bust my
chops everybody's so busy with their
crap lately no one ever comes like I'm
not busy oh no or I'll smack you through
the wall like last Monday last Monday
was a fluke Bring It On woman
whoa this guy holds it down being the
kooky old man in a lot of movies Vanessa
she's the one not getting any handsomer
I know that every day I get a little bit
older and Baler and fatter it's okay
you're still beautiful man when I was
your age I could eat anything I wanted
wouldn't gain an ounce now I have a
chocolate shake my ass Jiggles for like
a week wait till you become the guy and
click he'll eat sweets all the time and
you won't change until later morning you
must be wrecked Pepsi clock let's go I'm
a Pepsi girl in a Pepsi world yeah could
I have a night light NightLight think I
can help you out hang on oh you're cut
out for this man your childlike
intellect allows you to connect with
him of course nice of course
bunny are you my dad a yes no I'm not
but that whole dad and mom thing we'll
figure out in the morning okay I'll be
your big
daddy damn wiggle wiggle wiggle thinking
about keeping the kid remember that time
you went with me to the pet store to get
fish food and you saw that cute little
puppy and you wanted to get it but then
I reminded you about feeding it and
cleaning it and toilet training it yeah
well this is kind of like that except
with a human yeah this is big I got to
do something big with my life I think
Vanessa will respect that yes women get
pregnant to try to fix a troubled
relationship why can't a guy adopt a kid
to do the same thing I didn't think of
it like that but yeah that's good that's
a good point yet I'm I would to make
that argument cuz that works every time
I was wondering you still got a foster
family lined up for Julian uh yes we do
well you can cancel him I I've decided
to take care of the little guy way to
sleep on it pal you two want to get
married I support that leave me
alone hold that over them forever
parents take the responsibility I mean
there's absolutely no bigger High that's
it and good luck to you and your son wow
man part of me wants to go there's no
way that's my boy that's my boy shared
Universe it's all connected part of me
doesn't want to believe it could be that
easy but part of me is like we live in a
world where I guess it totally could be
these days the Sandler verse I wet my
bed
[Music]
a what did you say the what
now that's a load of that's a
that's a big ass stain dude it's okay
Scuba Steve was out
exploring yeah start start out with the
dog Theory and we'll move up from there
yeah just sleep on that kid you'll be
fine
Jesus yeah you're fine he's gonna piss
on that
too GNA start taking after him he's
going to start taking after you we're
going to be in a whole other
movie Adam Handler just regresses the
entire fil yeah it's like some weird
Benjamin Button
of course yep yeah that's
awful
this must have been fun to shoot P me a
ball he dressed himself whoa yes I hate
that got it I got it hey hey hey we can
fix this a it's okay that's a lot of
milk it's time to learn a classic adage
anything can be fixed with
newspaper it's really
can movie did wonders for the print
industry oh my God I felt that damn you
oh you tricked them there's a bright
side to being up before 11 we can catch
McDonald's breakfast yeah it's Pepsi
clock and McDonald's is a Coke company
can't believe they got away with this
wow the
Betrayal you help with that yes oh no
you don't no you can't Loop it you swoop
it and you pull Loop it swoop it and you
poop
it poop ity scoop that kid's shoes are
authentically dirty yeah confirmed dirty
ass kid with the dirty ass shoes he
brought his own shoes to set I have to
go to the bathroom we're going to be
there in a minute got to go now hey
didn't you peeing up in bed already
Never Enough hey buddy can my kid use
the bathroom for a minute customers only
oh yeah he's just a kid come on we'll be
in and out of here it's not my problem
wow what
a come on come back and pee all over
your table here yeah I put some
newspaper on it that's right hey yeah
what do you mean you can't do it you
said you got to go just go I'm scared
scared can you do it too
a all
right here we go let's both get a
citation right
here hey oh
wow flow let it go
the most endearing PC we're going
to I think it's the that's the cover of
the movie I know I've seen yeah I know
I've seen that side by side we're almost
there we're almost
therey why are you sitting on the ground
this is where I live little man why well
in retrospect I made some really bad
choices After High School oh no oh okay
we're going to miss breakfast why never
really thought about that kid I mean I
was never missed a popularity in high
school and uh I watched Fantasia a lot
and one day it just clicked sure if you
end the conversation I'll get you an Egg
McMuffin I got a sausage McMuffin with
hash browns you got a deal
yes oh no oh
no they better bring him that sausage
McMuffin with hash browns sausage
McMuffin what are you Tak a survey he
keeping a tally hi welcome to McDonald's
what can I get for you wow wow they used
to wear blue like that yeah wow a
throwback sorry sir we stopped serving
breakfast what are you talking about
what 4 seconds late no you're 30 minutes
and 4 seconds late we stopped serving
breakfast at 10:30 a hor oh oh
Jesus no no no don't cry I'm sorry I
wasn't cursing at you I was cursing at
the lady nice parenting hey thanks
you're my therapist take a walk wow you
got a Happy Meal can we get a Happy Meal
we stop to get the k a Happy Meal Jesus
Jesus
where's my egg McMuffin breakfast is
over at 10:30 really yeah I thought it
was 11: I thought that
too what do you want me to do what will
cheer you up you want to see me get hurt
will that cheer you up
some oh no this kid's going to grow up
to be oh oh my God okay this kid's going
to grow up to be a
sociopath are you okay man next time
kill
me you brought this upon yourself be
careful what you wish
for oh he pissed on you oh no you this
kid be this kid be peeing all the time
oh my
god oh I never had one of those the
cookies never had
cookies what are cookies you're missing
out
John cut the crap cut the crap I'm being
serious don't do that I'm being serious
don't do that why don't you go take a
nap I'm too hungry to sleep put him into
a coma oh
wow give him
diabetes no dude too way too loud too
loud dude you're going to wake him he's
going to be right behind you you chose
the crunchiest food of all
time
oh oh no the Phantom kid he's on the
ceiling what's this kangaroo and we're
going to watch this after the game okay
but after my nap I always watch the
kangaroo
song and there's a penalty shot about to
take place this happens like once every
10 years karoo song kangaroo sh kangaroo
sh karoo sh all
right the face make him cry
again oh
[Music]
I'm of course you are see the internet's
tainted my mind because I expected to go
really dark out of nowhere yeah yeah
yeah that's my favorite kids character
douchebag
kangaroo ran for 34
SE
Gross I'm scared what if she's not nice
see these right here these are magic
sunglass okay if you're afraid you put
them on they make you invisible really
nobody can see me oh no oh no julan
Julian hello Julian Sunny I'm right here
oh the glass I feel like this is going
to be some heartwarming call back later
in the movie yeah or he'll really turn
invisible and become a whole different
kind of
movie about magical artifacts and the
two of them exploring the magical realm
welcome back who's that who's who he's
invisible hey any invisible people out
here feel free to come in
okay this is going to go well we should
sit down you said I got some thinking to
do so I did it oh and instead of just
saying that to you I figured I would
show you before you say anything else I
just want you to know look at that he
took his sunglasses off he wants you to
see him that means he likes you a
Vanessa I want you to meet Julian my son
what our son I adopted him oh my God how
you long going to keep this alive bro oh
my God it's not going to work in your
favor my
friend somebody in the bathroom oh yep
ah hey open up Sunny hello it's open the
door it's sunny some okay I was going to
say not not who you'd expect it's big
daddy sorry it's freaking out there I'm
sunny it's a professor hey S I had an
attack of paranoia I thought you were
sleeping with my girl oh I am I am hey
there we
go oh this old guy Sid he's already
achieved so much and yet he's still goal
oriented and still focused he has a
5year plan what is it don't die
hey this is what you wanted Sunny you
surprising me with a kid that you
adopted while I was away wasn't what I
said I wanted I did this for you no you
didn't you did it for yourself homie you
don't want to L you remind me of my
oldest grandson you don't think things
true hey old man RI zip it or I'll break
your hip
try let's go fight come on you know deep
down you must have known this day was
going to come I know you're going to be
missing me when you got that big white
wrinkly body on top of you with his skin
and old balls gross
don't body Agee shame I
guess she likes that though she's about
it yeah I mean she she would have to
be which is cool you know a lot of
people like older people look I can't
manage this kid I I I ain't a good
father I I made a big mistake I had a
mother lined up for him
but no now we got to do it for the right
reasons kid just won't stop peeing and
throwing up he's like a crespan I just
SP I think he'd be better off with his
natural mother she passed away last
night Mr gity oh wow we'll take him but
I got to tell you man he's going to have
to chill for a while in a group home
group home what is that like an
orphanage yeah we don't call him that
anymore yeah this guy's good he's like
very natural I did it Loop swoop and
pull jeez you did do it you're teaching
them stuff
a That's my boy that's my boy and your
little condom
hat
why don't we pretend that you didn't
even come in here today okay and I'll
give you a shout when I line up a family
right got to make a phone call just just
stay right here all right very
fascinating like Choice with that
character cuz he's using like hip lingo
but it's not like weird no very natural
it's organic for sure hey Dad how's it
going how's Florida not too bad ah
Florida the state of the old and the
unhinged kind of adopted a kid are you
being a grandfather congratulations the
hell would give you a kid oh
no his mother's hang on hang on go play
with them pigeons buddy yes wise I just
can't that all right I I I look I need
your help I'm in a bad way right now how
many takes of that they have to do just
give that kid back before you ruin both
your lives oh I appreciate that Dad he'd
be better off living in a dumpster than
living with you shooting this like an
action movie right hit the the spinning
shot yeah know I care about you saving
money on this phone call
oh I know when you first got here you
thought you were going to meet your dad
but I got to tell you I don't think
that's going to happen real dads aren't
always that great you know I got a real
dad and the guy's out of his mind he's
been telling me what to do my whole life
he never lets me figure stuff out on my
own and now he lives in Florida what do
you want it to be Frankenstein all right
I can deal with that I'll call you
Frankenstein let's go scientist nice
good job kid right on Frankenstein now
on you do whatever you want to do and
I'll show you some cool along the
way don't play that that's what it's all
about let's go
scoob oh my God give me that pizza the
taco pizza method yes ah yes the New
York shoot a few beer cans or something
like that all right Ah that's a
dangerous game I wouldn't do
that I've not seen that movie but that
sounded painful I love that
movie this kid's going to grow up to be
a fashion
icon oh my God
no what are you wrong I say do whatever
you
want I'll have a hot dog with a mustard
and a KES Frankenstein what do you want
packets of we don't have those out here
all right 30 packets of ketchup oh
yeah thank you sir may I have
another oh shoot do that thing I taught
you the other
day
uhuh
CGI took like 20 minutes to learn man
he's quick smart and he loves ketchup
yeah he does he L of eat you know it's
originally a soup to be fair
ketchup it is it is tomatoes he's
technically eating vegetables right now
yeah a fruit
rather please help me I don't ah that
was using the kid to pick up on women
problem we'll just um we'll find your
parents uhoh there you are are you okay
buddy is that the friend of Leslie man's
friend yeah thank you so much for being
sweet to my little boy here I I think my
sister Karen is engaged to your roommate
you're a sister's Karen that sucks oh no
but you have a son now I'm not really
his dad I'm more of a temporary Father
Figure type until Social Services can
get another family for at which point
you'll have to find a new way to
initiate conversations with girls in the
park just see right through you could
you just hang out with me tonight I
don't want the kid to think he's a
failure because he couldn't get me a
date I really can I see hang on a second
come here oh what are you going to do
you melt her heart if you don't come
over to Sunny's apartment tonight
there's a good chance that I'll develop
a St
up oh what please don't do this to me oh
my I originally wanted to be a male
model but turns out I'm not very
goodlooking so that didn't work out what
what method is that I don't know I no
the cool down method what is that
channeling the energy from the heat into
her
Palm I can't go sleep until you say good
night I didn't know that I'm sorry good
night what do we learn about girls today
initiating the conversation is half the
battle fair I suppose you're right kid I
gave him M well he should be out for the
night excellent you're not a attracted
to like 60-year-old guys are
you no yeah I don't like him
either yeah got a lot of beef with 60y
olds I can't sleep but when he got
across the street turned out they
weren't cared they were smart you don't
sleep with the chain on little guy yeah
the peanuts belonged to a squirrel who
had taken them home from a baseball game
a the rabbit worked up his courage and
asked the squirrel if he could have just
a littlest squirrel
kiss squirrel thought it's just not the
right time in her busy squirrel life to
be kissing any rabbits oh and the rabbit
got shut
down a kiddo good night Scuba Steve good
night Scuba Steve here are the magic
sunglasses you put them on if you feel
scared okay uhoh I lost you I don't know
where you are PAL I'm sorry julan you H
oh there you
go a
I like your hat
a made a friend run away I think we may
have found a family for Julian uh why
don't you give me a call back as soon as
possible so we can set up a meeting
disconnect your phone SAR Club legal
department can I speak to Lea Maloney
you're a club eh I don't think you know
what's going down on the streets let hug
you in it's going down on the streets
when you're in an office seven days a
week Mr to a they get a real job where
are you no you're a big boy I think it's
cool you only work one day a week you're
a big man you're a big dadd daddy I we
make it stop itching I don't know you
scratch it rub up on one of those
scarecrows scratch it s I hear about you
doing laundry with my sister did she say
I was doing laundry witha cuz where I
come from is called doing the hibbity
dibity oh no you dog I got EG oh well
then you shouldn't scratch it hey don't
don't tell him what to do he can scratch
if he wants to scratch scratch
is that better thank you a now you two
get married scratching spreads your
ashes also this is something you learned
at
Hooters see you later Frankenstein hey
you stay away from the frozen food
section yours will harden ah I like that
people are just committed to calling
Frankenstein though yeah right it's cute
oh a real date who's watching the kid he
must be miserable without you right now
n he's in good
hands friend is watching him look at
Brad's body oh the two friends okay I
thought Rob Schneider was watching him
for a second what what movie is that
I've tried contacting him several times
and he hasn't responded I'm concerned
hey xay on the catchup no no no that's
actually a good reason to be working I
guess I feel like I got to kick ass
while there's ass to be kicked well you
kick that ass during the day but at
night you have fun with Sonny kick that
ass and then a night you go smack some
ass damn
stra
damn she's gonna she's gonna like teach
him how to be a man she's gonna mom
she's gonna be big mama and he's big
daddy she gonna become Martin Lawrence
by the end of this movie that's
right and then Brandon T Jackson we get
him in there it's going to be the whole
gang all the big
mamas maybe we should try a kiss out we
owe it to ourselves to see if we should
move to the next level see if any Sparks
Fly I'm not sure w
come on let's just let's just give it a
shot just so I can have some dignity at
home oh my
goodness oh oh you going kiss him oh sh
he just went right in too oh my God
gross did I just witness the first kiss
yeah you did Karan thanks a lot for
showing up oh it's perfect hey what do
you got in the bag Karen some chicken
wings dles shut up you have a good sleep
tonight there Karen Pleasant
Hooters Jesus Christ man you do this
every waitress you meet Julian has been
displaying some odd behavior last week
he spilled a tube of glue on the floor
and didn't tell anybody he just covered
it with
newspaper uhoh one of our students wore
rollerblades for show Andel and Julian
tripped him with a stick
a found it hilarious I like him to feel
like he can express himself freely I've
really never seen any problems with that
it's on the
you you are a modern parent his personal
hygiene is becoming a cause for concern
he's the smelly kid in class as he had a
bath oh yes I've had some smelly ones
before but your son is by far the
smelliest oh no oh no presentation of
the founding fathers in two weeks and
Julian has drawn the part of Benjamin
Franklin a very important role you
should do what you can to help him damn
I'm sorry I mix up D and L uh Anthony
Macky why you turn that game off pal I
got four guys left come on let's study a
little bit it's twisted metal time you
can't tell me what to do really how
about we take a vote who thinks the kid
should start studying who doesn't well
you just lost two to one no it's a tie
that guy doesn't count he can't even
we
hey oh Scuba Steve
oh I'm Scuba
scuba Steve's father you see my boy
needs to take a bath so I was wondering
if maybe you could keep him company in
the tub oh my and after the bath you
have to try and study hard cuz if you
want to be a member of the scuba Squad
you have to be smart
sure the good news is you're starting
not to smell like a foot anymore hey you
make this a regular thing you know
bathing and studying and
eating right not him using a blender
yes oh got the drip drip I guess he
wouldn't notice the kid smell because
think of how much the place he lives
must smell true just masking part of the
environment just accustomed to it see
urinal are good too oh and they got the
whole gang in there doing it right oh no
don't sew the seeds of infidelity we
already got used to one one gay couple
in our friend group to have a third gay
person is going to break everyone's
mind oh interesting that's that's
actually kind of a good idea if you
clean it out right yeah it's clean it's
not
horrible
he hip hop Hip Hop Anonymous they call
me the Hip Hop apotamus my lyrics are
[Laughter]
bottomless oh no
rro
whoa Steve you owe a sausage
McMuffin get out there at 10:30
oh my name is Benjamin Franklin I was a
writer a diplomat an eventor and a
Statesman although I only went to school
for two
years invented many things we still use
today well done kiddo great job your
father and I are proud are you I'm
straight man so
cute a little
spectacles he adorable hello Mr kofax
hey Mr Brooks how you doing you just
call me Mr kofax though didn't you it is
your name isn't it sunny kofax uhoh you
fraudulently held yourself out to be
Kevin G to gain custody of young Julia
wouldn't check his I problem in this
state Sunny well I've delivered to you
before you always order three pieces of
cheesecake oh no the kid has to come
with me now or I'll have you arrested
but two policemen downstairs doist sunny
I would like to help but my status in
your country is not what you would call
Legal oh no you've done enough already
you don't want me here anymore that's
not it pal you just got to go away for a
little while how long am I going away
for ohuh I'm thinking we're going to be
seeing each other anymore a you going on
but he's going to see in this moment
what a good dad you are you deserve it
me go funny I don't know what else to do
I won't play the kangaroo song
anymore just go you got to go you got to
go come on
a I'm sorry I don't even like that song
anymore I know that's not it but I want
my own ass I want my own ass
I
know
oh help me get him back who Social
Services I got to get him back oh what
can we do I filed a brief to get custody
based on the best interest of the child
and Tommy knew one of the clerks so they
FastTrack the hearing it's Tuesday you
got to be there oh damn I got to go to
Washington there's a hearing to dismiss
my case well can you get somebody else
to do it it's your case I can it's my
case yeah what about Julian's case we
don't even know where this kid's going
to end up she can't drop her whole life
for you I had things going just the way
I wanted and then I'm sitting in the
park and you and this kid just come
barging into my life and it's it's
screwing up everything I had planned
yeah a kid showed up on my doorstep you
think I planned on that but I fell in
love with him a so now my plans have
changed now I actually have a plan sort
of an 18-year plan yes yeah right or a
13-year plan yeah there you
go a second you turn 18 you're out of
here get out of here you're done T cast
aluchi Arthur Brooks social services and
representing sunny kofax plus I'll
pretty much be representing myself your
honor damn anyone else Lea Maloney your
honor oh she's giving up her life for
you isn't his actual daddy a lawyer too
we went to like Japan right yeah Mr
kofax is a really cool guy wish my dad
was as cool as him you see my dad was a
military man guess I wasn't such a good
soldier you look like Lieutenant Dan
when I was 35 years old he got tempted
to give me a crew cut while I was
sleeping one afternoon I woke up broke
his arm haven't seen him since I'd
rather live out on the streets than
under his freaky ass rules
woof
hey oh yeah that's the stuff I think Mr
kofax should be acquitted of all the
charges if OJ can get away with murder
why can't Sunny have his kid sure and
how long have you been delivering food
to Mr kofax I deliver food for 6 years
plus I'm stripper I've put on weight so
it's problem you're a de Bigalow and in
your experience was sunny a good father
to Julian oh yes they make terrific pair
so Sunny still also doesn't have a job
he's got that one day at a to
Booth maybe you like spaghetti and
meatball be more comfortable with that
anology yes considering we're in America
I mean if you don't like spaghetti and
meatballs why don't you get the hell out
yes not my problem your father was sick
oh hey stop yelling at me oh buddy
excuse me am I in the right room hey who
the hell are you I'm his daddy coax is
co-counsel he has enough
co-counsel not today and did Mr kofax
appear to be an attentive and loving
father he certainly did and how long
have you disliked Mr kofax since the day
I met him yep where did you work while
you attended Medical School God damn it
Hooter just Just Let It Go people we can
let this one go Jesus Christ that was
not relevant whatsoever this is just you
and me talking so don't even pay
attention to all these people okay can
you tell me how old you are he's
five ah beautiful
beautiful now can you tell me how old
you are five do you know where you were
born Toronto Toronto I thought you were
from Buffalo I moved to Buffalo with my
mommy and for the past 6 weeks you've
been living with sunny right
oh I remember her what kind of things
would you do with sunny he taught me how
to do a sleeper hole Like Chief J bow he
taught me how to pee on a building oh my
God that's right I say what can I say
pretty cool right do you remember the
last thing your mommy said to you was
that she loved me and I was going to
live with my new Daddy and if your
mother could pick anyone in the world to
be your new daddy who do you think she'd
pick Sunny a a and not his actual dad
who's right next to him you can be my
uncle Dad yes and which of your esteem
co- councils will be examining you my
father oh damn dude okay your honor
there is nobody in this world who thinks
I shouldn't have a child more than that
man back there he also happens to be one
of the most respected lawyers in all of
Florida this man just knows every lawyer
in America
yep he going to add councils until this
thing's done your honor this case is
simple it is absurd to think that Sunny
kofax is ready to raise a child
objection shut up Tommy oh how did this
sweet little boy Julian end up under
your supervision I told social services
that my name was Kevin G I pulled a
school of rock so you're lying yes like
the time I found a bag of pot in your
underwear drawer and you told me that
you thought they were pencil
shavings my son doesn't have health
insurance he doesn't how to boil an egg
he filed for Social Security at the age
of
30 to give this young man custody over
another life is not only wrong it's
insane oh if I get custody of Julian
I'll be his father forever and that
scares you because you think there's a
good chance I might fail it's more than
a chance you're going to fail you can be
scared that I might get pickpocketed in
a bad neighborhood but don't be scared
about me being a dad because I will not
fail at that I can't can't I love this
kid
too you work in a toll booth don't be
scared about me making money I am in
love with a beautiful girl who makes
plenty of
it to be my sugar mama that's literally
what I was about to say I got to get me
one of
those yep get all the McDonald's you
want I would die for this kid just so he
wouldn't have to feel one ounce of
sadness that's why you're here right now
to protect me to be scared for me a to
be a good father and that's exactly what
I'm going to be oh it's so Earnest damn
dude my son deserves this
kid he should be the lawyer yep yep yep
we did it made
[Applause]
it the fact is you kidnap this child not
only shouldn't you get custody but since
you obtained the child by defrauding the
state of New York you should be in jail
ouch youan I think you can't take him
away oh oh as that boy's father I
refused to press charges wow K I'm sorry
just six years ago Joe Carter Joe Carter
Toronto and the Phillies you know World
Series oh no there was a girl I was so
hammered you know Canadian beer is like
moonshine hell yes I'm sorry Karan I
know this changes everything but I had
to do the right
thing Court grants custody to Kevin gy
pending the results of a DNA test
[Music]
no a i you to be my dad hny a cuz it
seems you already have a daddy but I'll
tell you what I can do I can be your
friend no matter what all right I'll
always be your friend a I'm going to
leave you with your dad now Julian he a
good man right here I've known her my
whole life so you two have fun and I'll
see you in the morning for breakfast
quit scaring a kid for a minute no
scaring the hose I just got back from
China do you know where that is China
that's where it was by Europe uh uh
brought some cool stuff back oh
o did you move the
bench that's pretty funny
huh
[Music]
a take us through the
Montage all we've been through in the
last 90 minutes
a year and three months and six days
later well I'm working on a big case I
got to sue you for making me
come now he's a lawyer too oh look out
oh we going to the we're going to
Mecca
a going to the place it All Began sunny
I beat you so bad in basketball
yesterday well then I guess from now on
I have to stop letting you win I stopped
letting him win 6 months ago he still
beat me hey can we get some curly
fries oh
you're a Hooters girl what happened to
Sid's 5year
plan damn dog maybe it's a 10-year plan
is that the GU the
old okay I don't think you're supposed
to testicles
okay leave the leave the people of
Hooters
alone ah free spray free spray
oh Dennis Duan I know that name I know
that name Steve Franks that's right oh
my God who's Steve Franks Steve Franks
creator of one of the greatest shows
psych oh oh I love psych yeah he uh he's
the creator of Psych and he co-wrote
this movie oh shoot and so there are big
daddy jokes in Psych which uh would
track due to that they're big daddy JPS
in Psych every now and again they'll
like bag on big daddyy yeah okay maybe I
never caught it cuz I never saw the
movie and I think that must be Christy
Swanson because then Christy Swanson is
Marlo on psych she gets married to
Lassie yeah okay okay okay
yeah goodness that stacked cast and all
that stuff well dude I mean first and
foremost guys if you're watching or if
you're listening to this on Apple or
Spotify once you go ahead and give us a
little rating there I can't tell you
what to do but I think five star is a
great place to start uh you know just
lets the algorithm know that you like
what you're hearing and that you want to
support and uh and hey speaking of
support this movie had a tremendous
amount of support from a whole bunch of
reputable Brands like Pepsi and Campbell
and freet tole and all of their various
chip and sweeties and whatnot um but you
know one piece of uh it was Christy
Swanson hey uh one piece of uh you know
representation brand uh recognition they
didn't have on screen was thank you to
Shopify for sponsoring which is what we
use for our merch store and is our
gamechanging partner in e-commerce you
don't need to be Text SA to understand
it allows individuals and businesses to
create and manage online stores offering
tools for sales payments marketing and
inventory management it's worth trying
out because of its userfriendly
interface face extensive customization
options comprehensive Suite of features
that cater to businesses of all sizes
their checkout system unmatched it's 36%
more effective at converting visitors
into buyers than other platforms and
let's not forget Shopify magic the AI
tool that elevates your business with
minimal effort but seriously reflecting
on our journey using Shopify for www.re
naations shop.com it's been
transformative the transition smooth
growth exponential thank you again
reject Nation from simplifying sales to
scaling our offerings Shopify has been a
Cornerstone of our success and Shopify
isn't just for us it Powers 10% of us
e-commerce backing businesses big and
small in over 175 countries there are
war-winning support always there to
guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all overc case shopify.com reex start
your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team but
without further Ado uh did you
appreciate uh uh papy Grande papy Grande
yes I did I did appreciate papy Grande
puty Tad that I did that I did I like
this movie I like this movie A lot it
had a lot of heart and all the
performances were very genuine and I
don't I really enjoyed the relationship
between our little man and and sunny and
I just wanted to Revel in it more you
know because it was just such a it was
just such a a lovely sweet experience uh
no I think
uh yeah in in its total in its
totality uh I thought this was really
funny I liked all of the little pranks
and gags we had going on I thought it
had some interesting things to say about
like you know fatherson relationships
and watching him kind of mature cuz he
realized he needed to step up for this
kid and this kid kind of finding a sense
of home within Sun
and yeah it was it was a lovely time it
was a lovely time John what did you
think as I formulate more thoughts I
thought it was a lovely time too I've
been sitting here wondering if they
named him Sunny
kofax uh so as to evoke the name Sandy
kofax who is a you know I believe a a
notable baseball player and I know Adam
Sandler always be mixing sports stuff
and here he's watching hockey and things
so I'm like is this a reference or not
but that's beside the point no I I I
enjoyed this quite a bit this was an
interesting one cuz uh like this one
while it feels like a very natural
vehicle for an Adam Sandler type
performer uh it doesn't feel as much
like it's weird there are ways in which
it feels like a quintessential Adam
Sandler movie and there are other ways
in which it doesn't as much or it
doesn't feel like what I would come to
and I forget where we are on the
timeline we're in the 90s at least so
like you know we're still kind of
building to what the you know definitive
kind of Adam Sandler movie would be
um but yeah I thought this was really
charming and and yeah it has that
perfect quality of like oh this guy
who's a Manchild is you know completely
over his head but also those Tendencies
are probably what's going to help him
really bridge the gap and bond with this
kid and I mean like there's more I
appreciated that they didn't completely
shy away from like the implications of
the actual like scenario that they're
playing out here I feel like I would be
curious to see what this movie would
have been had it been made maybe at a
slightly different moment in time
because I feel like now you know we live
in a in a moment where people are going
to be asking a lot more questions about
the premise in general like this is one
of those movies where I could see
somebody not being able to oh that's a
nice little dedication this movie is
dedicated to our fathers thanks for
putting up with all our crap we love you
note to Cozy Adam also enjoys your
hamburgers this cool they got a shout
out in the but uh but yeah this uh it
was interesting to see this concept play
out because I can imagine certain people
uh certain types of viewers being very
hung up on the logistics that get us to
him essentially it's like if he didn't
call back with cold feet he would just
be this kid's legal garden and like
nobody would follow up or be any other
the wiser right right so like there are
things about that but but you know being
in the era that this is from you know it
wasn't too distracting to me and yeah
like even though there are aspects of
this that did make me wonder and and you
can see kind of multiple directions a
movie like this can go in terms of what
the circumstances are going to be and
how it resolves itself um yeah like this
uh I
thought it was I don't know I was trying
to find like the exact words to describe
it and I don't feel like I have found
them yet because yeah I really enjoyed
the cast and this definitely feels like
a a 9s romantic comedy of sorts and it
does have its focus kind of split
between like you have to do him bonding
with the kid and and sewing the seeds
for us kind of watching him grow into an
actual father figure but there's also
like a romantic comedy element uh you
know with the sister and all that stuff
and uh and yes like this isn't an overly
it's not any longer than a traditional
romantic comedy or comedy would be so
part of me feels like maybe it could
have done with like an extra 10 minutes
or something just to flesh a couple of
those things out but but for what we're
here for I mean I thought the cast was
all really Charming it's fun to see like
John Stewart in you know a role and
Leslie man of course and uh and who
played it was Christy Swanson who was uh
uh his ex who he was like obsessing over
but who was the sister cuz that was a
that was a thing that like yeah I
thought it was Jennifer Tilly but it was
not she's got that kind of a voice and
like that was a Charming detail to me uh
cuz like Lela is Joey Lauren Adams
goodness I I I know I must have seen her
in some other stuff but uh but yeah like
that was an element where where I
thought they were really endearing and I
think that you know there's often a
romantic comedy element to a Sandler
joint and I thought the two of them had
really lovely chemistry that sold a lot
of those scenes and and yeah once you
get to the sort of wrap up and you're in
the courtroom it's like this kind of it
falls in the middle for me in terms of
like how it wraps itself up because you
think to yourself This can go one of two
ways either we can find some kind of
impossible set of
circumstances that uh will legalize this
scenario and and he'll get to keep the
kid or which was more of what I was
expecting would be them to do something
kind of like this where they go to court
and they confront the actual legality of
the scenario and come out thinking oh
well you broke like you broke the law
beyond your ability to be a good dad so
like this probably isn't going to work
out exactly how you want it but there
will be some way that you guys can still
be each each other's lives so like it It
ultimately goes there which is which is
the thing I was expecting more and that
I appreciate it's going for that Nuance
although at the same time it's not doing
a whole lot to be like here's the sober
reality and now you know we're getting
to some kind of Bittersweet resolve it's
it's you know the the lightest feelg
goodest version of it which I don't
begrudge a movie like this um but yeah
it just makes at least a viewer like me
think of like all the different
Alternatives that that could have
happened in a story like this but the
nuts and bolts of what we're here for
the important parts you know watching uh
uh Sandler and and little C Dillan
sprous you know watching them Bond and
everything and uh just the the fun
little sketches and sets set I guess you
call it a set piece there's nothing
really super elaborate but you know like
the little bits and things that happen
are super charming and that core
relationship is very endearing and I
feel like that's the main thing that's
important and then you have all the
other like you know random supporting
characters and whatnot yeah yeah no I I
definitely agree I feel like this movie
asks you to forgive a lot because there
is some stuff that seems sort of
unrealistic in the sense of like how he
was able to go so long without the legal
system getting involved over the course
of yeah this hour and a half because you
think you need an ID to like verify like
and paperwork and whatnot I just snort
it I don't know uh this one of those
things were part of me is like in real
life this would be way more complicated
but then I think to real life scenarios
where I find myself going I thought this
would have been more complicated like
there should be more safeguards so yeah
like it's a feel-good movie you know and
I felt I felt good while while watching
it you know it does it does tug at the
heartstrings it does do that thing that
it's supposed to do and sure yeah it's a
light movie and it's funny watching this
because the last movie John and I
watched as of recording this was uh
Happy Madison seeing like the parallel
type of characters that he would play
Happy Gil oh my bad Happy Gilmore what
did I say Happy Madison fair fair I mean
Fair Billy Madison and happy more fused
to make the production company name yeah
right right right right right okay uh
yeah but I would say there's a lot of
similarities and type of characters that
he plays and you know at this point in
his career like that that kind of
character works for him and it's I don't
know it was it was interesting watching
that after watching this last movie and
you know I in a realistic sense like
maybe he probably wouldn't get the kid
but like I'm happy that he did because
you see you know that they kind of teach
each other something in a sense you know
he teaches him about maturity and then
you know
he the kid teaches Adam Sandler to be
more mature and then Adam Sandler
teaches him about like The Facts of Life
you know in his own Manchild kind of way
and yeah it it it made him find a new
place of new sense of home you know cuz
prior to this movie he lost his mom you
know and he was like this kid that was
lost and like he was scared and like
this guy made him feel loved and even
though he was doing it for the wrong
reason reasons at first cuz he wanted
his girlfriend back he found he found
like the love and the sincerity and like
what and he learned to not be selfless
or not to be selfish yeah and yeah like
I love characters who can go through an
arc of you know doing something that's
higher than themselves because you know
that's I feel like that's what life
should be you know just finding
something that's that's greater than
your own your own needs okay this is 99
Sandler so this is like we're actually
kind of it's interesting this this to me
felt like it could have been earlier
than some of the other ones just because
the like the other ones that we've seen
thus far I think skew more Broad and
more High concept oh she was chasing Amy
that's where I've seen her before I have
never seen Chasing Amy great yeah uh but
but I mean I think that's that's an
interesting note of this because yeah
it's like you look at a water boy or
Happy Gilmore or any of these things
like there's a broadness to The Comedy
of this movie most certainly but it
almost felt a little less broad than
some of the other things that I'm used
to seeing up until this point and I I
feel like this could also be kind of
hailing maybe a slight shift toward you
know the more dramatic Sandler that
would eventually kind of uh arise
because even though he has his sort of
like wise ass personality that he often
has in this movie his Ang it's not like
as cranked up as a lot of his other
characters are and I think that's an
interesting thing he's still playing a
character not a
caricature yeah and I mean it's still
relatively familiar for like it's it's
you know a version of an Adam Sandler
essentially uh but at the same time yeah
there's like an earn I think the real
nice thing about this movie is like I
feel like a lot of the other ones we
watched are surprising you with the
earnestness despite how broad it is and
certainly this has that quality but I
thought this was more Earnest more
directly more of the time than a lot of
those other ones where like the earnest
uh thread will like pop out and surprise
you whereas here it felt kind of like a
natural curve into that and like pretty
much right away you see the good nature
in this guy coming out or at least the
fact that like yeah he's he's got this
hairbrain scheme to get his girl back by
adopting a kid but the whole time he's
still pretty concerned with the kid's
well-being and teaching him stuff and
like not losing his patience and
whatever like there are a couple moments
where like oh yeah he wants to keep
sleeping so he puts the kid on
newspapers but like there's so many
opportunities where it could have gone
like ah you know he snapped at him and
he went too far and he yelled at him and
now the kids are like you know there
there were certainly like a lot of
cliche things they could have done with
like the actual fatherson Dynamic that I
think they avoided that were nice um and
yeah like once you get to the end it is
at least that thing of like okay there's
a I think there's a bit of a a muddling
of like the emotional payoff like I
thought that thing with his dad in the
courtroom was really nice and that whole
thing of like yeah I want you to come up
here and cross-examine me and prove why
I shouldn't be as sort of a
philosophical demonstration of
understanding of like the sacrifice and
the Nuance it is to like be a parent and
like those things I thought were really
nice and and coming to that emotional
resolve of like man this dude really
does deserve to have the kid like I I
think that's a good thing it's a nice
thing but I I think there's like a
tempering you could do and it's like the
movie still does the tempered version by
the end because you're watching as uh as
Julian is learning to you know play with
and learn from his actual dad John
Stewart and that's like a nice lovely
little moment they leave us off on while
it's you know we kind of understand that
Sunny will be the kid's Uncle
essentially and then he's got his own
baby at the end um yeah it's it's it's
I'm trying to figure like I feel like
there's a thread I could that oh
continue keep going there's a I feel
like I could see a movie a version of
this movie that's more that has a little
bit more drama in it like I was
interested even though was played for
comedy until it sincere at the end there
was this interesting relationship we
could have explored more between sunny
and his father sure and you know why he
turned out the way he did cuz I they
dropped a bomb at the end of the movie A
minor bomb but the fact that he chose to
to hang out with his friends and then he
missed his the the death of his aunt and
her funeral yeah like what's going on
there like why what was that all about
and you know how did his relationship
with his dad play into the kind of man
that became like how is he the one
slacker dude in this group of lawyers
like what's what's that about you know
how did that come to yeah and they're
all like all of them are
lawyers and everyone in his life by the
end is representing him somehow or or at
least involved in his case yeah yeah so
I thought I thought that was interesting
yeah and it's I guess it's CU that stuff
is so quick it's like we get I guess uh
I could imagine a version of this where
like the legal passage it's it's weird
it's like everything I come up with
that's like an interesting kind of note
of the experience or even things that I
would have wanted more of or or I would
uh venture to like critique about the
movie are all things where I'm like I
get why it's not proportioned this way
although part of me is like I feel like
especially the legal stuff could have
taken a bit more time just to like
really kind of not that it needs to
become like a legal thriller but just to
get you like I I forgot about Julian in
that scene until he comes out at the end
and I was like oh that's right that's
what we're here for right um and yeah
and then like it's it's fun to get all
your little wrap-ups and stuff at the
end you know I like I I don't personally
as a viewer need the punch down on the
Christy Swanson character or just the
meme of of Hooter like a yeah most
everything I most everything is is yeah
is on point but but yeah like that was a
thread having the gay friends I thought
was an interesting one because they make
a lot out of it and like whenever they
talk about it everyone's like how are
you adjusting to our friends being gay
yeah I like yeah I like that aspect of
things I like that they the joke wasn't
the fact that they were gay and I like
that the fact that it was like it was
weird yeah yeah cuz it wasn't like it
wasn't making a bunch of gay jokes and
it wasn't making a bunch of jokes that
they're like it seemed like the movie
wanted to be like yeah they're gay so
what but at the same time was trying to
integrate it was it was doing it like
ahead of its time like trying to
integrate uh people being gay into like
into mainstream movies and like not have
it be a big deal and I and I thought
that was very cool yeah yeah and it's
interesting to see that Circa 1999 where
you're like okay this if this was
happening today this would be handled
with more finesse because again it's
like once you find out they're gay
pretty much everyone's like I don't know
everyone is just constantly sharing
flashbacks of like remember when they
used to not be gay uh you know which is
fine but it's just one of those things
where I'm like oh it's it's a strange
beat because yeah half your brain is
like oh it's cool cuz yeah there are
just they friends they're all supportive
they're here for him and they rib each
other but you know whatever that's
that's cool but at the same time like
the tone of voice and the way we
incorporate that stuff I think has
changed certainly so I think like they
make an odd strain of Comedy out of it
even though it seems good-natured and
less like objectionable than a lot of
other gay jokes and a lot of other
movies and stuff and then uh and then
yeah just like the constant dogging on
Hooters I'm like ah we can move past
that now like we live became excessive
we live in a day and time where like
Hooters does not it doesn't pack the
same punch as like being a dead end for
your life you know like we all recognize
the the Hooters as an institution is a
bit problematic but also like people out
get and yeah and people out there you
know are making it work for themselves
and and you know like there's everything
under the Sun so like you know that
that's an a joke part of me has to
imagine that they paid for that although
I always wonder it's like brands have
gotten more Savvy especially in like the
as as like SNL and stuff has gotten more
viral they've been more apparent that
brands are like yeah you know use us for
comedy make jokes at our expense even
but you know we still sponsored this and
that's kind of how this feels with
Hooters but also I'm like but they are
kind of like using it as the butt of
jokes whereas like there's a ton of
other product placement that is just
product placement okay I think that's
what I was trying to say earlier like
even though they would make reference
and and comedy about the fact that
they're friends were gay I don't think
they were like trying to be like being
gay is a Bad Thing making the butt of
jok exactly I never felt like they were
punching down I feel like they were
like I punching laterally doesn't make
sense it just it just seemed like yeah
they kept like for the times cuz I feel
like a lot of people at that time
weren't publicly out so for them to have
them as characters in the movie but then
address it how people in the 90s I felt
probably would because they weren't used
to it on a regular basis I felt like it
felt you know it didn't feel like moment
in time yeah and and yeah and for the
moment in time I'm like this could have
been so much worse cuz yeah it is like
it's not like anyone's really joking
about them it's just everyone's sort of
being like strange we got these gay
friends now and they didn't use we
didn't used to know this yeah crazy
right you know but then they just
treated them as character they just like
on the most yeah like B at least
good-natured seeming kind of way yeah I
will say that it's funny because I feel
like the biggest buy for me in the movie
was cuz the sister and uh Adam Sandler
had good I think they had good chemistry
but I felt like it was kind of funny
that he went from remember what the the
girlfriend's original job what did they
ever say I forget okay but the fact that
he went from dating her and she's like
you need to do something with your life
to then him dating like a busy ass
lawyer yeah I felt like I I feel like it
didn't not that it didn't make sense but
I feel like the woman of that position
would have similar concerns to the last
girlfriend it's one of those things that
yeah because of the time economy of a
movie like this and because we can't get
over rod about certain things and
because the movie is being a couple
different kinds of movie at the same
time you don't get to flesh that stuff
as much and like part of me is like fine
cool it we don't need to draw this out
cuz it is like he happens upon her in
the park and at first I'm like well he
must have known that she would be there
because we've seen this character before
but then it seems like oh no this is
just an authentic attempt at using this
kid to pick up chicks but it also just
happens to be you bro watching thing
back so great let's let's do that and
then like and yeah it's like that could
have been it own romantic comedy but
because we're in this other scenario it
basically has to be that we see only the
most basic beats of like yeah we're
going to see him try to do the ruse
realize it's her they're going to hit it
off eventually they're going to kind of
mom and dad roll the kid and then you
know they'll actually get together oh my
God thinking back at this whole thing
I'm like
cuz cuz she didn't want to be a part of
this from the beginning like she want
they meet her at the park she's like no
I got to work then he uses the kid okay
I'll go back to your place and then she
didn't want to kiss him and then they go
on the date and then she's like no I I
don't still don't know if I want to kiss
you like come on I'm funny like okay
I'll kiss you and then they go to he
goes to a job after he loses the kid he
like I got this job thing I got to go do
but my job and my kid and then she shows
up and then a year later she gets
pregnant I was like dang I feel like
home girl would have had like a whole
life ahead of her had Adam Sandler not
inserted himself into it it does seem
yeah yeah there're just little questions
like that and little things that I think
again I'm willing to let go of for not
to say that she can't still have a life
but I'm just saying just the way that
they wrote the character felt like she
was very much about her career and it
wasn't like this Mutual falling in love
thing it was like Adam Sandler kind of
like like ah come on like Charming her
way into like her apprehension for them
to be together yeah it's like I think
that that for the wraparound for the
ending moment like them having a baby it
it works for the image you know it works
for like the the kind of ending you want
to have but yeah it's like in the
details of the movie and without having
like an extra 10 minutes to hack some of
this stuff out you are like oh
interesting like I could have seen them
getting together and and maybe planning
to have kids down the line or a little
further down the line than they are
right now because yeah she does have and
he says that thing about like you know I
I got you know someone who earns and in
1999 you know things were probably more
rough than they are at this point in
time and and in this point in time
things are already not great for you
know moms having careers trying to
balance both and and who knows you know
maybe uh uh he's the stay-at-home dad
like I guess that's what I would my head
Cannon would say I know we're leaving
realism at the door here but sure homie
became a a lawyer in like a year is that
possible can you just do
that well he went to law school and
stuff what I'm guessing is he did all
the study he went to law school
something like that yeah he he graduated
law school and then it's probably like
he just needs to brush up and then pass
the bar or something like that is my
guess but yeah it's like it's all there
and there are certain elements where
you're like oh yeah I could have used a
little more flesh on this or that or or
or yeah things that you're kind of left
to fill in at the end what my guess is
that she probably works and he raises
the kid um but yeah all in all this was
quite Charming it was quite heartwarming
I thought yeah the relationship between
sunny and Julian was quite dear and uh
and yeah enjoyed a lot of the supporting
characters to a lot of you know Sandler
regulars uh you know Rob Schneider
playing another you know
uh I can't remember how many times he's
played like a middle eastern guy or or
I'm always curious about like he's
always showing up in like a different
ethnicity or some kind of wildly
different thing yeah was didn't he
played something else in water boy right
he like you can do it yeah he's that guy
and then we just I saw click just
recently and he was like a Saudi Prince
or something in that movie like yeah
he's in a bunch of the Sandlers then
obviously uh uh Steve bimy was a nice
surprise uh and then yeah Leslie man in
here and all that stuff and Christy
Swanson was nice to see her for a hot
second there and just all the other you
know main supporting characters again
his friends uh just everyone I thought
was quite Charming his dad like that was
a nice thing because we see him like the
once and then we come to the very end of
the movie and it's like oh we're having
like a really touching heartfelt scene
and so yeah this this movie had a nice
blend of all the things in some variety
I think like you know again this is one
of those movies that gives me a bunch of
different views of if you just tweaked
one element or another element it could
look a slightly different way but for
what it is and again what the point is I
still thought this was very Charming
very funny and uh and yeah I can see why
a lot of people like would really
Embrace this movie in particular yeah
I'd probably give it like a like a six
and a half yeah I'll go like a seven you
seven yeah seven out of 10 yeah yeah
yeah I feel like I'm curious like
because again now the more we of these
the more we're going to have to like
rank them up and this one I think I'm
going to have to maybe chew on because
it's not quite as like all the other
ones I've seen so far are sort of what I
expected in terms of like intensity of
energy and this is the most sort of
different than the attitude I was
outwardly expecting in that yeah I think
I was going into it expecting like a
boss of thewall Comedy but it had like
more heart than that and like it was
still comedy but you know it was it had
had a decent balance you know especially
WS the end but yeah guys it was a fun
time did you guys like watching this
movie do you like watching this reaction
tell us what you guys think in the
comments like comment bring that Bell uh
and yeah we look forward to seeing you
guys in the next one guys all right well
with that being said adios y'all
[Music]
peace